[Music]
the huge success of battle royale games
such as sport night and player unknowns
battlegrounds has created a big draw to
the shooter sub-genre with lots of games
putting different spins on the formula
apex legends might be the best one yet
a combination of an intense focus on
team play with specialized player
characters similar to what's seen in
games like overwatch every element of
Apex legends homes in on one particular
experience in Battle Royale teaming up
with a squad to be the last one standing
and by doing that it excels if you've
played a battle royale game before now
you get the rules player sky dive down
onto a big island full of structures
landing with nothing but their wits
everyone runs around finding weapons a
loot to use to defeat the other players
and be the last one standing
apex legends forgoes the single-player
version of battle royale though at
launch it only has one mode that sees 23
player teams square up against each
other the success of Apex legends is in
combining good ideas that have worked in
other shooters that includes the three
player focus and some of the smooth
movement and climbing mechanics of
response titanfall games although be
warned titanfall fans there are no giant
robots or wall-running here
there's also a revival system that lets
you respawn fallen teammates if you can
recover a specific item from when they
fall it adds a harrowing bit of strategy
that requires risking everything
you can only respawn players at specific
exposed places but one clutch play can
bring back a team from the brink it's a
system that keeps you engaged in matches
and your teammates progress instead of
just quitting to jump immediately into a
new game the biggest addition is the
roster of Legends apex is a character
shooter very similar in approach to
blizzards overwatch in which you start
each match by picking a particular
character who has particular abilities
in apex they're called legends and each
has three different capabilities that
change the way they play one drops a
defensive shield for teammates another
can heal the squad and another can
obscure the battlefield with smoke
grenades combining character abilities
to complement each other builds on apex
esteem focus you can spend a lot of your
time thinking about teamwork and
strategies because apex avoids a lot of
the little annoyances that tend to
plague battle royale games a big part of
these shooters is inventory management
as you decide what items you need and
what you don't usually in a menu apex
legends streamlines that process by
automating a lot of things like adding
attachments to guns if an attachment
fits your gun it's equipped
automatically if you trade that gun for
another gun all the attachments you
currently have equipped get traded to
the new gun - emaux is all color coded
so you instantly know what kind you need
for the guns you're using an apex lets
you know if the things you're about to
pick up are worse than the things you're
already carrying the inventory system
just works and it lets you keep your
mind on winning instead of worrying
about what's in your backpack then
there's the ping system which might be
apex legends crowning achievement aiming
at anything in the game and pushing a
certain button lets you mark that thing
on your team screens
bings are contextual so picking a spot
on the map will suggest the teammates
that you go there but pinging a weapon
will call out its type and location in
case another teammate wants it back back
here level one you could do so much with
the ping system from asking for ammo to
marking enemy locations that it's
possible to play whole matches of apex
legends without talking to your
teammates at all and in a lot of cases
highlighting where something is with the
ping is much more efficient than trying
to describe it perfectly anyway like in
respawns previous games shooting is
hefty and satisfying an apex sports a
wide variety of cool guns that all
handle a little differently but one
thing that can hold gunplay back is that
a lot of guns have small magazines and
players with armor have a lot of health
that can make weapons like submachine
guns and some assault rifles feel pretty
underpowered and constantly in need of
reloading which is risky when you're
fighting someone without any backup I've
seen a lot of apex players using
shotguns because they just seem much
more reliable in a fight than many of
the automatics that can spray ammo
everywhere
apex Legends is free-to-play which means
it includes microtransactions for
cosmetic items like character skins you
can pay for currency that lets you
unlock items or buy loot boxes which you
can also earn through playing the one
sticking point for microtransactions is
that you can also purchase new legends
with - you need to unlock by playing or
paying at launch
we found earning the characters took a
really long time it took me at least
fifteen or sixteen hours according to
origins play timer paid characters
aren't better or worse than the free
ones but since the differences in
Legends add so much to the game the
grind to unlock them is probably going
to turn some people away
[Music]
the combination of smart shooter ideas
from across the genre makes apex legends
a blast of a competitive experience
because it's so full of elements that
work so well together
respawn has done a great job of
freshening up the Battle Royale formula
while addressing a lot of its weaknesses
it's a big step forward for Battle
Royale
one that should inform where it goes in
the future
[Music]
you